the los angeles home called the one
which the developer had hoped to sell
for a reported 500 million dollars is
being sold to fashion nova's owner
richard sagian for less than half that
lofty amount the house is being sold for
141 million dollars during a bankruptcy
auction through concierge auctions this
week more than double the previous world
record for a u.s home auction the house
was originally listed at 295 million
dollars developed by nile miami the huge
over 100 000 square foot estate took
more than 10 years to build and created
a huge debt for nyami twice the size of
the white house it is one of the largest
homes built in los angeles it spans over
3.8 acres features an outdoor mode of
water on three sides of the home and a
400 foot outdoor running track the home
is reported to have 21 bedrooms 42 full
bathrooms and seven half bathrooms the
home has five swimming pools including
one impressive indoor pool a full
service hair salon and spa a putting
green a ten thousand bottle wine cellar
tennis court and even a nightclub
it offers a 360 degree view of the city
skyline the san gabriel mountains and
the pacific ocean
the builders development company
crestloid filed for bankruptcy last year
which forced the home to be auctioned as
part of bankruptcy proceedings the sale
needs to be approved by a bankruptcy
court judge which could happen later in
march currently billionaire and hedge
fund tycoon ken griffin's 238 million
dollar new york penthouse in 2019 holds
the record as the most expensive u.s
home ever sold